[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey Rolly and everyone watching this
each major my name is Caitlin I'm your
panel host and this is operation Ember
ice now let's get started by watching
this quick video by ubisoft news
operation ember rise is bringing that
supa hot fire to Rainbow six seeds with
two new operators and a newly reworked
map the defender bringing the heat is
Goa
who can use his Vulcan shields to create
strategic cover points deny entry to the
attacking team and serve up the
occasional operator flambe
the attacker rising to the challenge is
amaru her Gaara hook can quickly zip her
up to rooftops exterior windows open
hatches and skylights we've got the
details you need to know about the new
operators as well as a tour of the newly
reworked canal map first up is Goya this
operator from Mexico's FES unit is a
savvy tactician who can rapidly deploy
his Vulcan shields to stymie incoming
attackers the Vulcan shield shares all
the attributes of a deployable shield
including the new look and the new snap
to doorways feature but the Vulcan
shield has a surprise
anytime Goyo his teammates or even the
attacking team sets off the incendiary
core attached to the back of a Vulcan
shield there's a small explosion
followed by a prolonged oh my god it's
all on fire effect that you definitely
don't want to try running through the
explosion can be triggered by damaging
the cord directly or destroying the
shield entirely so Gordon Tessa Sarah
Lee have to stick around and be the one
to set it off in fact this medium speed
medium armor operator can be quite
deadly while either roaming with his
vector 45 ACP or hunkering down with the
tcsg 12 shotgun if things go bad his
shields are still a threat even after
he's been killed especially when paired
with a cap gun trap but the threat goes
both ways
while Thatcher's EMP grenades and
twitches drone can't disable the
incendiary core and Ike you can't detect
it the Vulcan shield is still a
deployable shield at heart meaning it
can be destroyed and the explosion
triggered by a frag grenade or ashes
breaching round you could also use
Sofia's impact for need or sledgehammer
this is fine on top of that anyone with
a clear line of sight to the incendiary
Corps can set it off meaning a poorly
placed Vulcan shields can work against
the defending team the goal with Goyo is
to leverage the power of the Vulcan
shield and deny entry to enemies at
critical moments or simply by your team
some time early on when the attackers
are pushing or when the round is coming
to an end
trigger your Vulcan shields to keep them
away from the objective or cover your
flank a well-timed Vulcan explosion can
be the difference between lighting up
the scoreboard or going down in flames
while Goyo seeks to impede the movement
of his enemies the peruvian attacker
Amaru
can get around the map like no operator
before this is her Gera hook and it lets
her zip to any repel able ledge or
window to quickly position herself where
defenders aren't expecting her to be and
once she's inside the building Megara
hook lets her travel up through open
hatches and skylights that's a first for
Rainbow six siege and defenders will
have to adjust their strategy
accordingly or pay the price when it
comes to choosing your destination the
Gaara hook makes it easy clearly showing
what it can or could grapple - you can't
crapple to something that's too far away
or too far below your position but you
can use the hook for horizontal
traversal as long as you're entering a
window once inside a building you can't
target anything but open hatches and
skylights while the hook will instantly
break a wooden barricade on a window a
castle barricade will prevent you from
even targeting it and a closed hatch
will need to be opened before you can
ascend through it Amaru supernova or ITA
12's shotguns will come in handy if
defenders leave those hatches
unreinforced this makes Gaara hook entry
a bit noisy so team communication and
good droning are all the more valuable
Amaru doesn't pull her gun up until
landing from the grapple so she's
completely vulnerable to kapkan and
frost traps lying in wait not to mention
any defenders who may have heard her
entry coming operators who can give her
a quick buff like finca or use their
gadgets to distract defenders like yin
or Doki be our strong pairings for Amaru
but with medium speed medium armor and a
g8 a1 LMG in her hands amaru is a
well-rounded and very mobile force to be
reckoned with all this action has been
taking place on the newly reworked canal
map the map is still split between two
buildings but an additional bridge has
been added to increase building to
building movement options there are
fewer windows around objective sites and
the rooftops have been reconfigured to
make run-outs more risky and additional
staircases and color coding throughout
both buildings have been added for more
rotation options and easier call-outs
the reworked canal map will be free for
all players when operation ember rise
launches the two new operators go and
amaru will be immediately available for
year for pass holders and all other
players can unlock them seven days later
with renowned or r6 credits for more on
Rainbow six siege subscribe to this
channel and visit us at News Ubisoft
comm now to talk about operation MRIs I
am joined by senior level designer
jeremy dassit as well as presentation
director Alex Cavazos now that we are in
North Carolina Alex how does it feel to
be back here at a major it's beautiful
it's sunny out it's a great time to talk
about it season three and we will be
receiving all of your offer your Intel
for the second half of the panel as
usual and Jeremy any interesting run-ins
with bourbon and barbecue there's been a
few run-ins with barbecue pretty much
every night the food here is amazing the
just everyone I've met is so lovely to
talk to is such a great place to be all
right well let's get started with your
map which is the canal rework this is
the latest rework to come the last one
being cafe and this is one of the
original maps of siege now canal has not
been available in the Ring playlist for
almost two years
so since September 2017 so many of you
will be happy to know that with this
rework canal we'll be coming back to
ranked that's that's correct we've we've
gone through top to bottom on this map
when we've totally reworked it obviously
adding a new bomb site makes it ranked
and compatible but you know if we talk
about the problems with the map you know
we've gone
we've really looked at navigation we've
looked at sound we've looked at lighting
it's gonna feel like a comfy pair of
slippers but it has you know and you
spice to it that's official
so first let's compare it to the cafe
rework to get kind of a scope with this
project because of course this we
haven't seen canal and rank so much for
so long
presumably it would have required a more
thorough overhaul and you worked on this
for nine months almost a year it was
about nine months worth of work out the
team and I started working on it around
Paris major time last year so it's been
nine months of looking at the map taking
it apart obviously trying to fix all of
the issues with it so speaking about the
issues was so breaking those down now
the most obvious problem that canal had
was the choke points yes now is one
building to the east one to the west and
before there was just one bridge
connecting both buildings how is this
addressed the first thing we did is we
added a bridge off of control room which
now gives the new rooftop access as well
so you have two bridges you have the
original bridge still in the same place
there as it was as it always has been
and then as a new bridge one floor up so
that aids in the rotation the other
thing we did is we went through me added
stairs we know that two sets of stairs
or two flights of stairs are always much
better than one flight of stairs so
we've added an extra set of stairs into
both buildings so now each building has
two stairs and of course the choke point
has been pretty opened up in the middle
and what's what's happened now is when
you go and plant you know up see it
comes out soon it's a much more of a
roamer friendly map and the rounds play
an awful lot more differently than they
used to because the way the rounds
played was people would wait to the last
minute and then they would basically
just rush in and smoke or whatever so
now what you're gonna find is people are
clearing the building they're actually
going because they can actually get to
the objective rather than weighing
outside all right and then we should
also talk about the other elephant in
the room which was the spawn cakes one
of your favorite things to address yeah
after the the closet window and villa
sprint eat the c-4 towards fountains I
learned from that one quite well so what
we've done is we've gone through and
we've looked at all of the run outs and
the run out possibilities and we've made
sure that anyone that wants to run out
will be detected before they get to the
edge of the roof
in most cases so if you really have your
heart set on running out you still can
be detected so it turns into more of a
1v1 scenario it's yeah it still can be
done you know yesterday we were playing
with a bunch of the creators and you
know they will run out on you and they
did but you know it becomes a one-on-one
it's possible but it's dangerous right
so it's a little bit more skill which i
think is what you're going for yes
awesome and then of course as you
mentioned can I also received a lot of
the same upgrades that the cafe rework
had which is like sound propagation
destruction is a lot more clear now
lighting updates as well we've got the
team went through and did an amazing job
the art team especially going through
and color coding stairs the sound team
did a great job because it is a big map
and there's a lot of love doorways and
windows so we went through and we
touched everything there's a lot of
line-of-sight floors now so you can play
the you can't defend from below so it's
actually really quite really quite fun
in his it's quite balanced this that I
enjoy playing it I guess in your where
is that our team actually went rogue
yeah we had a wet with the Dillman said
it would yeah they would rogue so what
happens is as we've changed metrics over
the seasons basically we had to move all
of the walls by 5 centimeters that means
they had to touch the shell anyway and
whilst they were region king the shell
they just went from redid the entire
thematics of the buildings and it looks
absolutely superb and so we'll see when
we're going through the map that when a
wall is destructible not only does it
look destructible but there are those
markings on the ground just for anyone
who's new to the game or has kind of
issues about looking for destructibility
so now what we're gonna do is we are
going to start breaking down every
single bomb site on Canal and we're
going to start with the second floor so
are you ready to go through the entire
map Jeremy I'm good to go alright so
again we're starting here on the second
floor the objective here is server radar
we're gonna be spawning in at sail boat
which is to the south and we're going to
be going straight there
so the spool points in this map haven't
actually changed at all so there's still
the three major spawn points sailboats
flowing docks and construction there's
new our assets nothing too serious but
there is some new stuff to block lines
of sight we're gonna go in through reset
what people would notice with reception
is we've actually changed the rotation
at the desks we actually aids in
navigation and if you look it's neatly
to the left archives as much wider now
as well the original bridge is still off
to the right and this is blue cargo and
you can see the markings there on the
floor to show you where the destructable
wars are and then you go through and
you're going to come up a new area which
is printer stairs which is a new rooftop
access and this access on the right is
there a way there's a window and then
you have the new tunnel that goes to
control room now control room radar used
to be one massive plant zone what we've
done is we've actually split it down
renovations are still there I know
people live renovations on the soft wall
so the plant zone is actually much
smaller so people have to commit all the
blue walls here are destructible and
you're into red corridor go towards
green stairs and then you're going into
server now server used to have the
corridor around it we removed it because
there was you get confused so the bomb
sites are side by side you can blow the
walls and have a lot of rotation it's
the line of sight and there's three
hatches in this area so this objective
especially it used to kind of feel like
sitting in a glass aquarium for
dissenters there were a lot of windows
that opened up directly onto the site
but we don't see any of that now
basically when we go through we start
iterating upon the map
I wish shut down all of the windows so
the first thing we did on this map is we
shut the windows and then bit by bit we
open them obviously like you say you you
felt like you're a glut in an aquarium
the gameplay is still there because
that's the flavor of the map you still
can actually swipe from the rooftop but
the field of view and the angles now is
actually much much finer so you need to
really time your shots pronounced are
harder typing is harder it's more
skillful yes all right so now let's move
down to the first floor there are two
objectives here
there is one to the West which is
coastguard mini lounge and then there is
one to the East I have that backwards
there's one to the east and no that
right okay it's Maps insecurity we're
going to map some security and we're
going to go up to the second floor first
and then we're gonna go down to the
first floor so maps and security had
Maps hasn't really changed too much but
it's people will recognize it
construction everyone's gonna remember
it hasn't actually changed all that much
there's a few new props but the path is
still the same from the spawn points
you'll see the nice new red stairs that
are covered to stop people come running
down and then doing early kills you will
get detected by the time you're at the
bomb you come in through construction
entrance and then we have the entrance
and if you go hard right you're going to
green stairs back up to server again now
what's really nice about this is with
the stairs and the walls it's really
easy to call out it's actually much
easier for people to navigate because
it's just just cleaner and much nicer
for the players you blow the hatch you
can drop straight into security now with
security if you remember there used to
be a locker room that's changed we've
put a door through now so you can
actually go between the two bomb sites
between laps and security and then the
kitchen is stood off on the right hand
side you'll notice there is actually a
window in projector just to the side so
you can still get shot out from the roof
or across the buildings and obviously
there's a window in kitchen if you want
to try and come through right and so
this is an objective that's being
changed so that you have to commit when
you go onto the site you really need to
get through the door and it's one of the
sites where you're going to find that
you can actually defend it remotely and
I think we'll see a lot of that being
played all right so let's go on to the
other objective on the first floor to
the west we're just going to spawn in
construction again so this is a bit of a
longer route to take and instead of
going up to the second floor first and
then working our way down we're gonna go
from the basement so and everyone
remembers coast guard meeting there's
been a number of significant changes to
this on this area but it's still gonna
feel quite familiar so rough a coast
guard again you can obviously see the
wonderful submarines that are dock there
you come through and the route we're
gonna take is we're gonna go down into
garage garage is now external rather
than being internal with the doorway to
the red stairs on the left-hand side so
this is now you know a place where the
defenders can't go so we've closed it up
a little bit obviously we're underneath
the new bridge you can see the windows
that go up into football and we're gonna
go into lockers lockers hasn't changed a
great deal everyone will remember it in
the ghosts brutal showers you go up the
hatch with Amaro's hook and then you're
straight into football half of this room
is destructible floor half of it isn't
there's a lot of destructible walls when
you come across blue corridor into
coast guard meeting everyone will
remember the 145 degree wards that you
in the map which is the split between
the two which is the split between the
two rooms go through complete line of
sight floor here and then what people
will notice is archives has changed it's
much wider there's a breakable wall and
there's a double door so it's less of a
choke if you're actually going to try
and attack from archives it's still hard
but you can do it nice
so still once again it's go for yes and
we also saw on Mars gadget being used
there as you mentioned I'm coming up
through the hatch which makes the
sending this site kind of tricky because
now you have to decide if you want to
reinforce those hatches which limits
your rotations it's it's a choice that
people will learn and though actually
the strats will evolve over time
obviously we've you having to reinforce
hatches you know you you make a decision
if someone's staying anchored in the
bomb site you can cover the hatch you're
gonna hear it get blown so it's not so
bad
but it does change the stripes a little
bit for sure all right so let's move on
to the last objective then and this is
in the basement
now the basement never had an objective
before of course this brings the total
number two for making it ranked playlist
compatible for this one we're gonna
start by spawning in the northwest at
floating dock and we are going to make
use of a new tunnel to get on site the
tunnel yes
so this area's changed quite a lot
everyone will remember Coast Guard
suppliers it hasn't changed it looks
exactly the same but we've read ink to
little bit when you start the floating
docking now go up right there's a path
that goes leads up to carpark and you
can drop down into a forklift alley as
the new tunnel goes all the way through
to the carpark as well and all of this
has been completely reworked so you've
got the new shell
you've got diving alcove and what we're
about to do is jump into diving which is
a new room in the far right hand corner
behind the scuba gear there's the set of
stairs that leads all the way up to
princess who goes yellow stairs blue
stairs up into printer you have a tunnel
the gums all the way from diving all the
way through to in between showers so if
you're getting pinched you can drop in
to drop into the tunnel but you have to
be careful clumsy defenders or an
attackers going to everyone can use it
you come through bathroom into the
basement corridor and then you're into
boat suppliers this will look very
familiar to people because it hasn't
changed all that much obviously there's
a bomb hatch there and we go into kayaks
which is a new room and a new bomb site
which is really good the way
wars are all destructible so we've
color-coded that and then you have
diving so you've got a lot of options
and it does the site plays really
interesting because everyone tries to
use the same old old strategy though you
know there's always a fun part of a
firefight on white stairs which is quite
fun but now it it changes because
there's different options so from your
testing is the tunnel more advantageous
for attackers or four defenders it's
really a 50/50 because it's a risk
versus reward to be honest because
there's a ladder and it does leave the
whoever uses it they're gonna be prone
when they're coming out the ladder so
that they can get attacked quite quickly
I find it really useful when you're
getting pinched and you're playing
lockers and you want to just get out and
rotate straight back down to diving all
right well thank you so much Jeremy for
walking us through the canal rework
again I'm sure many people are going to
be very happy to know that this map is
coming back to rains
I hope I'm it was always a very nervous
time for the dev team I I really hope
that the community loves it and I'm sure
that even though I've tried to stop all
of the spawn picks I'm sure that
someone's gonna find one somewhere but
that's the beauty of the community they
always learn and I learn from them well
you'll be able to play the new canal
rework starting some moral Monday August
19th on the test server so get out there
and make Jeremy and it seem proud and
now we will move on to the two new
operators of the season now these
operators are unlike any ones I've been
released before because they really
encourage player creativity and you can
play them how you really want to know by
this what I mean is that with a Mario
you can attack however you want and with
Goyo it doesn't matter if you prefer
anchoring or roaming because you can do
both with them even in the same round so
to talk about this we have Alex
hello Kalin so let's get to the bottom
of who Mario is first who is Emma right
so I'm root is an operator we really
haven't seen before she comes from a
civilian background not a traditional
CTU and she's made it her life's mission
to protect her heritage to fight against
traffickers of Antiquities and this has
really been her strong goal so someone
who's very morally strong and fights for
what she believes is right absolutely
and let's move on then to her gadget
first so do you want to introduce the
gadgets were players yeah of course so
the gara hook
is something that she actually made
herself and as you can see she gets from
point A to point B incredibly fast very
fast how fast it the travel time is
about 7.5 meters per second and we'll
get into that a little bit later on and
so the hook outside it works on ledges
skylights windows and inside it works on
hatches
so she's the very first operator who can
ascend up through hatches yes and like
Jerry was saying before this kind of
changes things up now for defenders
whether or not you have to reinforce
those hatches on defense so with so many
options of how to attack a site with her
what kind of player would be drawn to a
burrow someone who really enjoys
creativity this is the first operator
that's not really based on a roll it's
based on movement and we haven't seen
that before so there's going to be a lot
of freedom with that and I think players
who are very well accustomed to our maps
will really enjoy it so creative players
and again it doesn't really matter what
operator you go out with because she has
synergy with all operators really it's
really about playing with your team
making sure that their droning so that
you know where you're going where you
need to be it'll be a really good team
play operator all right so let's talk
about her loadout starting with her
primary loadout a Mario comes with
either a supernova or a g8 a1 so a
shotgun or an LMG and what's interesting
about this is that the supernova now
comes with a silencer attachment and the
LMG has an angled for grip now the
silencer that's not for sneaky shotgun
kills is it Alex not really
so for hatches you have to break them
first in order to get up them so the
silencer just helps her be not
announcing her position as loudly as
before and then with the LMG having that
new angle for grip means that she can
ready the weapon a little bit quicker
right because she'll probably be popping
up from a hatch maybe literally on sites
yeah and you don't want to spend a year
bringing that gun up to your face
absolutely alright and so for her
secondary loadout she has the option of
taking either a shotgun again which is
the Ida 12s or an SMG the SMG 11 and
what's great here is that even if you
take the LMG for your primary you still
have the option of taking a shotgun so
you can still open up
because they have to be opened off in
order to use the gara hook on them right
that's our designers just making sure
that you have some options to play with
and that everything fits with our kit so
her secondary gadget options are either
breaching charges or a claim or the
claim war is really useful if you need
someone to watch your flank so if you're
zipping around the map going through
hatches and you're worried that a
defender might follow you through the
hatches then it's useful to put down a
claim or to warn you of that right and
if you want the breaching charge this
opens new ways to flank to move through
some of the jungle of a map to make sure
that you get to the objective quickly so
both of them are good picks overall yeah
absolutely all right so then let's talk
about what I'm sure people are waiting
for and that is how do you counter Amuro
and we'll first touch on the strongest
counter to her which is castle castle
absolutely he reinforces the windows so
that an Amur can't break it with just
her gadget she'll need help from a
teammate or if she wants to use a breach
in charge on it that would actually slow
down incredibly and then after Castle
good picks against amaru our trap
operators yeah so if the team the
attacking team isn't droning they're not
checking what's beyond that window
what's beyond that hatch I could get
stuck really easily you just place them
underneath those windows and then a
really strong counter to her is actually
just map awareness and sound awareness
right so the design team spent a lot of
time with this making sure that the
window is broken so that you can hear
her reeling in it gives a little bit of
time for the defenders to anticipate
this and so if you have that one-on-one
confrontation with an AM reversed in
through a window usually the Emer will
lose 70% of the time just because of the
noise she makes and the readying time of
her weapon so she is a very fast
operator as we mentioned but you do have
the ability to hear her when she's
coming and doing something about it
right so it becomes important for an
amber player to play smart not too
aggressive and really use roaming and
quick speed to pop up one place and
disappear and read some
all right let's move on to the second
operator of the season then which is Gao
who is going out so coil has had a bit
of a tragic past he lost his father and
his brother at a very young age so it
was his mother who raised him and his
mother's best friend who actually
happened to be a marui so um route took
him under her wing taught him everything
he knows and that's why they have such a
close friendship yeah I don't mean to
add to the heat puns but just looking at
the graphics and everything you can see
that there's this like warmth between
them in this connection yes so we'll
actually have more to tell about their
friendship and you'll see it more with
the CG that we'll be releasing right
before the season starts all right looks
like about Goyal's gadget then which is
the Vulcan shield right so he gets three
of these these are the new deployable
shields that we'll be dropping in the
season as well he attaches this canister
that can be triggered by a ballistic or
by an explosion and it's really used to
funnel attackers into one choke point
trigger it and delay as much time as
possible so let's just touch on a few
things about the shield from the front
it looks like a completely normal
deployable shield right so already you
have mind games where the attacking side
sees the shield they have to drone it
out to figure out if it is a goya shield
or not and then they have to deal with
it
Ray said you started leaping over it a
defender could shoot it he'll be in
trouble yeah and then much like mirrors
canisters on her black mirrors if you
well anyone can shoot it however unlike
black mirrors and unlike mirrors black
mirrors twitter owns can not shoot the
explosive on the back of it right so
electricity does not affect it right so
don't think that you're going to be
getting those early phase prep kills
right that's specifically why the
designers made sure that doesn't happen
all right so let's talk about his
loadout coil has two options of very
strong guns to pick he can take either
the vector 45 or the tcsg 12 right and
so the shotgun actually comes with an
ACOG which means he can
very long lines of sight in triggering
his canisters and both weapons actually
play well with his ability to either
anchor or roam because his canisters are
deployed by anyone he can start out as
an anchor and place those shields and
maybe he can rotate somewhere else and
the teammate can actually trigger the
shield right so that's a really good
time to talk about how with coil you can
be an anchor or a roamer with them and
you can make that decision mid game even
in the exact same round that you're in
right and both this weapons work out
super well with that the vector is a
strong weapon either way what however
you play it and the shotgun too can be
quite versatile especially with the ACOG
you can use that roaming yes absolutely
and then for his secondary loadout he
has a pistol which is useful for getting
those vertical shots on his shield in
order to set it off yep it's just a good
default standby to trigger those shields
now for his secondary gadgets his
options are either c4 or impacts of
course impacts are great for roaming but
they're also good for setting up good
angles on his shields on sites but
either he can hit them or a defender can
hit them while he's off-site right so
impacts can trigger the shields and he
can be a bit more protected without
exposing his location and then you have
c4 which is again a great frigging tool
that you can have in your kit I'm sure
some people would never dare take the
impacts over the c4 yep and that's
totally their choice how you want to
play goya is up to you so let's talk
about his counters then countering Goyo
is really about making the best use of
you your utility right so these
operators that were singing now that
counter Goyo like ash and Sophia how
they counter him is by swapping one
charge of their gadget for one charge of
coils gadget so it's kind of one utility
for one utility it's not the most cost
effective way but is a quick option to
get rid of the shield that's right if
you come across the shield you don't
want to be delaying any time for your
team so these are two great options to
quickly deal with it and
and moving on to kind of a similar
counter to Goyo using consumables
so using frags to take out the shields
is another way you can get rid of them
right and it means that you don't have
to rely on that ash or Zofia you can
have some versatility in dealing with
these stalling tactics but one of the
most cost effective ways of dealing with
Koyo it's taking operators like buck or
sledge and then using the charges on
their gadget to get verticality on
Goya's shield and then just shooting it
yeah and this becomes really important
for a good Goyle player to make sure
they're placing these fields and places
that you can't get those line of sights
vertically you can't destroy the floors
and then get that nice angle in it and
of course just anyone shooting it with a
bullet that will absolutely do it so
that is the first look at both a Marui
and Goyle both of these operators will
also be available to play starting
tomorrow Monday August 19th on the test
server and now we're going to talk about
other upcoming features of the season
war with Alex yeah and we have a lot of
them yes there are a lot we'll start
with player behavior changes first
though right so the player behavior team
has been working really hard on some
quick fixes that actually really
improved the game so at the start of the
season what you'll see is leaving
escalation penalties so if somebody's
been leaving quite frequently will step
up the penalty that's applied to them
and it should encourage players to not
leave intentionally on top of that we
also have will be detecting if somebody
is afk at the start of the prep phase
and if they have the diffuser they'll
actually drop it automatically at the
start of the round that way you don't
have to team kill to get that diffuser
on your team then during season 3 we'll
be introducing a couple of more changes
which is squads and Earth's friendly
fire so we know we've been listening to
the community feedback reverse friendly
fire has been working really well but
there is this failing where squads can
team up on one individual player they
can pick on them and they don't get a
sanction applied so
now we'll be talking about the squad as
a total we'll be getting that reverse
friendly fire sanction as a group so as
especially appreciated if you're someone
who's solo cues a lot yeah these are
really small changes that make a big big
difference and now let's talk about
upcoming changes to the playlists yes so
we started last season with a lot of
changes for ranked and that's really our
endgame content we want players to be
playing ranked playlists it's the most
rewarding it's the most competitive and
we want to make sure that we help
players get to that content so one of
the changes we're making right now is
introducing a new rank called the
champions rank this is above diamond
tier above 5,000 MMR anybody who reaches
above this will be assigned a number and
they'll be compared to other players who
have the same rank then we're talking
about rank distribution we've changed it
up a bit you'll see the bell curve now
lies a little bit closer to the silver
and we've added more ranks at the lower
tiers this way you'll be progressing a
little bit more steadily and it means
that gold is a little bit more important
now when you do achieve that rank
we have a change to the map pools that I
know people will be excited about
so for ranked we're actually reducing
the size of the map pools we're taking
out hair furred theme-park and fortress
and we're adding the new canal rework
and you also see casual will be reduced
a little bit more just so that it's
easier to learn the maps that you're
playing and you're well aware of what
you need to do yeah so hopefully this
will reduce the entry barrier to siege
because a lot of people coming in to see
you will get overwhelmed by how many
maps there are even for people who are
already playing now you can focus on
learning and mastering less Maps right
and these are going to be our most
competitive maps that we're listening to
the community for so it should help out
a lot and then one last thing to
announce is a new playlist that's coming
to siege which is the unranked playlist
this is ranked rules without all of the
stress of actually playing ranked so you
now have this in-between between casual
and ranked that players can
progress through and feel confident in
when they want to play ring so this is
especially useful for people who really
suffer from ladder anxiety yeah
absolutely
all right so we are also going to
announce that CH is getting a battle TAS
Rainbow six siege is getting a battle
pass in year four the battle pass will
be deployed in two phases
phase one is the mini battle pass named
call me Harry it'll be short seven days
and seven tiers and completely free as
you play you earn battle points that
unlock tiers and rewards so the more you
play the more you earn upon completing
the pass you'll receive the unique Harry
chippy charm
call me Harry will be available during
operation amber rise phase two is coming
in season four this year it'll be a
full-fledged battle pass here's how it
will work there will be two tracks a
free track and an optional premium track
you progress through both tracks by
playing and earning battle points even
if you choose not to unlock the premium
track you'll still be able to collect
the wars on the free track so while the
battle pass is active everyone gets more
rewards for playing finally through the
battle pass you will get to learn more
about Harry and the operators of Rainbow
six
Alex tell us why siege is getting a
battle pass so the battle paths that
we're developing is a new monetization
product but it is also important for us
to bring players back that they're
excited to come back get rewarded and we
want to make sure then that the battle
pass is something that's generous
something that's fair and it's also our
way of injecting more story now into the
Rainbow Six universe and why are there
two phases for the battle bus this is
something we've never done before so we
want to make sure we do it right so
season 3 we have the smaller mini battle
pass that'll be free that way we get
feedback we can test it out technically
to make sure it works and then Season
four we open it up it's a full battle
pass with more tiers more cosmetics that
you can actually get rewarded for and a
bigger story that we're telling and the
video also said that while the pass is
active you get more for playing what
does this mean exactly so we always want
to make sure that the battle pass is
inclusive so even if you don't buy into
the premium tiers you're still getting
rewarded for all of the time that you're
putting into the game and there is
character Laura that's side to this
right so this is something that's really
exciting the pass will come with
descriptions and stories about our
operators about the actual cosmetics
that you win season four actually will
have a motion comic to that'll set up a
prologue that we'll talk more about SI
20/20 well thank you so much both Alex
and Jeremy for coming and talking about
the upcoming season the pleasure
absolutely welcome and we're not done
yet because we have an announcement from
the eastwards team
[Applause]
now to talk about the pilot program is
Stewart a manager from the youth sports
team thanks a lot for having me we're
super proud to announce phase two of the
pilot program and its member teams today
so Stuart tell me who is in the pilot
program in North America we have Evil
Geniuses and space or evil geniuses and
rogue returning joined by Space Station
gaming in Latin America we have team
liquid-phase clan the newly christened
MIB R and int Zed eSports in Europe we
have Penta returning with g2 natus
Vincere and team empire joining the fold
and over in a pack we've got cloud 9
Norah Rango and fnatic and what is the
overall goal behind the pilot program we
want to extend our support to all the
organizations and players within the top
level of our community to make rainbow
six eSports a viable career path for as
many people as possible what's changed
between this version of the fellow
program and the previous version that we
saw before
so scope and scale for starters we
wanted to expand the number of teams we
support we wanted to support players
directly through this and we changed up
a couple of the revenue sharing
mechanics as well so let's get down to
the brass tacks
we saw the pro team skins how does the
revenue share for this work that one's
pretty straightforward
it's a 70/30 split between Ubisoft and
the team respectively 30% of those
revenues that a team makes are also
forwarded to their players and the pro
league gold skins are we still going to
be seeing those of course they are a
staple of the pilot program these days
we've tweaked it a bit from version 1 of
the pilot program now in phase 2 it's a
70/30 split evenly as opposed to a 70
21:9 this is to account for the
increased number of teams in the pilot
program itself so we can support more
and how does the Rhodes of six
Invitational tie into the pilot program
so this one's a bit different this time
around so beyond just contributing to
the six Invitational prize pool we've
added a mechanic that acts as a
performance incentive for our pilot
program member teams basically how it'll
work imagine a hypothetical scenario
where you're the only team participating
in six invitational so base prize pool
is 500 grand
you get 1.5 million from the crowd
funding from Road Disick's Invitational
as the only member team there you would
the players would take on 1.25 million
the org would get 750 thousand of that
thank you very much Seward for
explaining that to us and as the use
words team have anything else to
announce we do we're
super happy to announce that our pro
league season 10 finals are sold out we
have over 4,000 fans going to join us in
tow Konami Japan huge thank you to our
Japanese community for coming out in
force and making this one of the best
events and of course to close the panel
out we will now reveal the next elite
skin welcome to the club
Mira
[Applause]
[Music]
that was the first look at operation
ember eyes pinkie Rowley everything here
will be playable starting tomorrow once
again on the test server Monday August
19th don't forget that date and stay
tuned